how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about the thing
that we love the most Marvel and of
course the Marvel Cinematic Universe
today we have some really awesome news
about black panther 2 some news about
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and just
good news about phase 5 of the MCU that
is coming up in general coincidentally
good news for phase 5 means that we have
good news for phase 4 because if they're
working on phase 5 stuff right now that
means they're pretty confident with
their phase 4 release schedule as it
sits currently which is great because
that means that we're going to be
getting Black Widow in November and then
of course some Disney Plus shows coming
up right after that as well so I'll
break down this good news but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe to stay
up to date on all the Marvel content and
everything happening in the MCU and also
for your chance to win this week's
giveaway a Marvel Iron Man Funko pop to
enter all you have to do is subscribe
like the video and leave a comment down
below about the video so in the midst of
all of this pandemic news in the midst
of a lot of uncertainty we have some
really good news black panther 2 has now
been listed on a production grid to
start filming and according to this
production grid black panther 2 is going
to start filming on March 1st of 2021
and that's about ten months away and
that filming date makes a lot of sense
considering the fact that black panther
2 still has the release date of May 6th
of 2022 now what's really interesting is
that it says that it's going to be
filming in Australia the first black
panther film although a lot of people
think that it was filmed in africa it
was actually filmed in Atlanta for the
most part the majority of the filming
took place in Atlanta however it looks
like they won't be shooting in the same
studio that they shot at before
now black panther 2 relied a lot on CGI
most of what we saw was CGI but what's
really interesting about Australia is
that it has a lot of different terrains
it has jungles it has deserts but it
also has the ocean this is something
that Atlanta does not have because you
have to wonder why they're not shooting
it in Atlanta again the first one was a
massive success and other Marvel movies
are shooting in Atlanta currently in
fact guardians of the galaxy vol 3 which
we're going to talk about in just a bit
is filming in Atlanta as well so why is
black panther 2 filming in australia and
it's just speculation on my behalf right
now
I think it's because of the ocean and
why do they need the ocean because blacc
panther2 is going to involve Namor now
of course they use underwater tanks and
a lot of CGI for underwater scenes but
if you're going to have a film that is
going to heavily involve an underwater
group of people you're probably going to
show large bodies of water a lot and you
don't have that in Atlanta and you don't
want a CGI an ocean so you have the
ocean but then again you also have all
of the other scenery that you need to
make the film look like it is shot in
Africa now remember the writers of
Avengers endgame did confirm that they
did put a name or easter egg in the
movie they said sometimes you plant
seeds sometimes they grow hinting that
name wars debut is right around the
corner and again it's just speculation
but to me it seems like they're choosing
Australia to shoot black panther 2 at
because of the ocean around it which if
true definitely means that Namor is
going to be in black panther 2 which he
is a rumored to be now the production
summary doesn't say anything about it
because they know that these get out it
just says more adventures with T'Challa
the king of Wakanda aka the black
panther but I firmly believe that Namor
is going to be in black panther 2 and
then we have a production grid for the
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 they plan
to start shooting in February 2000 21
February first in Atlanta Georgia now
this is great news because we didn't
really know too much about guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 it was actually
supposed to be in phase 4 but of course
James Gunn got fired and then rehired
and got brought on to do the new Suicide
Squad and can't work on guardians of the
galaxy 3 until he finishes that so we
don't have a release date for guardians
3 but it starts filming one month before
black panther 2 starts filming and black
panther 2 comes out in May of 2022 so
that means we could probably expect
guardians to come out early 2022 or late
2022 and hopefully finally get that
debut of Adam warlock that was teased at
the end in the post-credits scene of
guardians vol 2 but this is great news
because the pandemic is dying down just
a little bit movie theaters are slowly
starting to open back up and production
at studios are starting to kick up again
so that means that Marvel seems pretty
confident in their phase for release
date schedule and hopefully we'll find
out more about phase 5 soon so let me
know what you think about this awesome
news in the comments down below and
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU for live updates you can
follow me on Twitter and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof